[Music]
covert 19 is less severe in children
most have mild infections or are
asymptomatic
some however have long-term problems
after recovering from an infection
extreme tiredness
shortness of breath
memory loss
and underperforming in school
you're seeing a considerable number of
young people who are not only infected
but who are seriously ill again the
numbers compared to the elderly or less
but that's a false comparison these kids
are getting sick
should children get vaccinated then
brazil canada japan and many other
countries have already begun inoculating
children over the age of 12.
the uk is waiting for more data to see
if kids should be offered the jab
[Music]
to jab or not to jab that's the question
facing many politicians and parents i'm
ben fazel and welcome in a moment i'll
talk to an expert from oxford first this
report from southern germany
katarina knows just where and how she
caught the corona virus
while at a friend's on october 29 2020
the 15 year old's life has been an awful
ordeal since then
i still have really bad shortness of
breath and also frequent headaches and
pains in my limbs and lungs and i can't
concentrate on some days i can't get out
of bed and of course there are moments
when i feel down
katarina's doctor is peter ilsinger who
says her case is far from an exception
he's been treating over 30 young people
suffering from long-covered symptoms
i see a lot of parents with teenagers
who don't know where else to go
they've already been to other doctors
and clinics
and unfortunately a lot of parents and
children were not taken seriously
but just how common is long carpet among
children and teenagers the short answer
is frustratingly that nobody knows one
of the few options for youngsters in
germany is this children's hospital in
munich where specialists are only just
beginning to understand long covet among
the young
it's an age group with very few severe
cases of covet but there are regular
instances of long covet especially among
teenagers and the sheer range of
symptoms makes it difficult to provide
either a diagnosis or a therapy
right now we have very little to offer
in terms of therapy there's still a lot
of research to be done
and making a diagnosis is also very
complicated of course
so providing a proper analysis requires
a very large number of specialists
the data available are thin on the
ground comprising a handful of
scientific studies with disparate
results
amid ongoing uncertainty there is now
hope from a study being conducted by the
children's clinic at airlines university
hospital
an mri scan is used to visualize changes
in the patient's lungs while complex
blood analyses are performed to display
possible cell damage
children there may also be issues that
we can't see properly our study aims to
provide new insights in this area such
as what scars and infection leave behind
in the body of a child or a teenager
the doctors hope to gain a better
picture of long covet among young
patients in order to help those affected
as for katarina she's essentially lost
nine months of her young life to covet
and while hoping her deal will soon be
over she's now looking forward to
getting back to life as normal and to be
able to go back to school in september
just like any other 15 year old
let's bring in dominick wilkinson a
professor of medical ethics before we
get to the ethics what do we know about
long covert in kids because doctors say
youths with mild or even asymptomatic
infections may experience long covert
yes that's right
the studies
on lung covered in kids
suggest that a small proportion of kids
have symptoms that continue
for weeks or even months after an
initial infection
i think the the best evidence that we
have today suggests that this is less
common
than in adults that that the majority of
kids
symptoms are short-lived that their
symptoms resolve within a week and then
perhaps only two percent of children
have symptoms that continue for more
than two months so i think that that
although this is certainly a concern
it's less common than than in young
adults or other adults does it make
sense then to vaccinate children to
ensure they don't get something like
long covered
well there are
a range of different reasons why we
might want to vaccinate kids we might
want to vaccinate them to stop them
getting acutely ill
the rate of acute severe illness being
in hospital or even dying
is very low in kids that's good news we
might want to vaccinate them to prevent
long covered or other forms of illness
we might want to vaccinate them to
prevent disruption to their education we
might want to vaccinate them to protect
other people so there's a range of good
reasons
why we might want to vaccinate kids
in germany there's no official
vaccination recommendation for children
and adolescents aged between 12 and 17
only those at special risk in the us the
cdc recommends vaccination without
restrictions
is there a right or wrong in that case
well there are two different
uh questions so so one is what what's
the relative
risk of uh
i've covered for kids what's the risk of
the vaccine and
so does the the risks outweigh the
benefits for kids of having the vaccine
that's a scientific question and there's
an ethical question about whether it's
the right thing to do to give the
vaccine given what we know the u.s have
taken the approach that given this is
generally a safe vaccine that they've
accumulated data
um that covert can be severe in kids
that the the best thing to do is to
offer the vaccine to kids
other countries have taken a more
cautious approach like germany and the
uk
and said
this is this
is a milder illness in kids
sorry we just lost you there for a
second let me pick up on the risk of the
vaccine itself what about the potential
side effects on children i mean how long
until something like that is known
so that's a very good question and one
of the main reasons to be cautious
is the possibility that you roll out a
vaccine and then find
rare severe side effects
and the worry is that not only would
that threaten vaccine confidence in the
wider community in relation to covid
that it might actually affect
people's confidence in our wider
vaccination programs which are
enormously important
so what would you advise parents
who have the chance to vaccinate their
children
well i think if the vaccine has been
approved and is available for
adolescents
i think that parents can be reassured
that the evidence suggests that this is
a safe thing to do and that it will
help the young person
uh
protect themselves and protect
those around them so i think if this is
if this is available that that it is
something that i would support
i think there's a separate question
about whether it should be available
um the big question then will we get
this pandemic under control without
vaccinating children
and so that's
partly about
whether we need to vaccinate children to
achieve a high enough immunity level to
protect other members of the community
so this idea of herd immunity
we certainly can achieve very high
levels potentially of of immunity within
the population
without vaccinating
children
in in the uk
more than 75 of adults have now had two
doses of the vaccine and there are very
high levels of antibodies among those
who
who haven't yet been vaccinated
including children
but because this virus we've already
seen has a
a
a tendency to to mutate
uh it's not clear that we can achieve
in practice something like herd immunity
so
it may not be necessary or helpful
to vaccinate children in order to
protect the wider community
professor of medical ethics dominic
wilkinson thank you very much for being
on the show today
you're welcome
your turn to ask the questions now is
our science correspondent derek williams
[Music]
can vaccines affect your menstruation
cycles tell you up front again uh the
answer is once more we don't know but
this is yet another of those questions
that's really worth some discussion so
let's look at it a small percentage of
women um under one percent according to
the reliable sources that i read uh
those women who received covet 19
vaccines have reported on social media
and
via side effect tracking apps
that they experienced subsequent
short-term changes in menstruation um
often the complaints were of heavier
than usual bleeding or or changes in
cycles the problem is
anecdotal reports like those in and of
themselves don't really prove anything
if if there really is a link to vaccines
it would have to be verified through
observations in studies
the large-scale clinical trials that led
to the authorization of vaccines
focused mostly on whether more serious
side effects could occur they didn't
really track
things like menstrual irregularities
which is not to say that for a few women
at least a link doesn't exist just that
it would be hard to prove experts say
because
menstruation can be influenced by a wide
range of other factors as well not least
stress and there's there's certainly
enough of that to go around
in this pandemic
that's that's just one reason why
demonstrating
clear causality would be pretty
difficult but but by its very nature
the female reproductive system is
certainly influenced
by the immune system
in major ways so
a lot of experts don't rule out the idea
that a vaccine
might have an impact
on menstruation although
pretty much all of them also say that
even if it did
the effect would almost certainly
only be a short-term one
thanks for watching stay safe and see
you again soon
[Music]
you